camila y ernesto necesitan un litro de
pintura anaranjada para terminar la
piñata gigante que están haciendo para
las festividades de la escuela
camila tiene dos quintos del litro de
pintura roja
ok creo que esto nos va a servir dos
quintos de pintura roja mientras que
ernesto tiene un medio del litro de
pintura amarilla tiene medio litro de
pintura amarilla ok si deciden mezclar
sus pinturas para formar pintura
anaranjada esta cantidad es suficiente
para terminar la piñata ok no olvides
que necesitamos un litro un litro de
pintura anaranjada para terminar esta
piñata gigante y nosotros lo que tenemos
es dos quintos de pintura roja déjame
ponerlo aquí dos quintos dos quintos y
también tenemos un medio del litro de
pintura amarilla entonces también
tenemos
un medio del litro de pintura amarilla
ahora lo que quiero que te des cuenta es
que vamos a mezclar estas dos pinturas
por lo tanto lo que vamos a obtener es
la suma de estos dos quintos del litro
de pintura roja más este un medio del
litro de pintura amarilla realmente lo
que vamos a hacer es sumar estas dos
fracciones ahora el problema que tenemos
es que no tenemos el mismo denominador
esta fracción tiene como denominador
este 5 y esa fracción tiene como
denominador el 2 por lo tanto no estamos
hablando de una suma de fracciones con
el mismo denominador así que para sumar
estas dos fracciones lo que necesitamos
es un denominador común y bueno habíamos
dicho que cuando nosotros tenemos una
suma de fracciones con distinto
denominador el denominador común era el
mínimo común múltiplo entre los dos
denominadores en este caso el mínimo
común múltiplo entre 5 y 2 sin embargo
también podemos ver que 5 es un número
primo y que 2 también es un número primo
por lo tanto el mínimo común múltiplo
entre 5 y 2 o mejor aún el denominador
común entre 5 y 2 y además que es más
pequeño va a ser la multiplicación de
ambos es decir 10 el denominador común
de 5 y 2 es 10 así que a esta cantidad a
dos quintos la vamos a transformar en
algo que tenga como divisor el 10 ya
esta cantidad a este un medio lo vamos a
transformar en algo que tenga como
divisor al 10 es decir que tengamos un
denominador de 10 muy bien y yo no
quiero tomar las sumas de estas
fracciones que ya tienen denominador
común lo que nos tenemos que preguntar
es cómo vamos a pasar estos dos quintos
a algo que tenga que ver con una
fracción con denominador 10 ahora para
resolverlo si se pregunta qué te parece
si lo vemos de una manera gráfica así
que para esto voy a traer aquí a una
barra que tiene 10 divisiones si te das
cuenta esta barra tiene 10 divisiones y
vamos a hacer que estas 10 divisiones me
den 5 partes
igual es así que para esto voy a tomar
el mismo color de los quintos y voy a
dividir a esta barra que tiene 10
pedazos en 5 partes iguales y si te das
cuenta aquí tengo una parte aquí tengo
otra aquí tengo otra aquí tengo otra y
aquí también tengo otra es decir que
esta barra dividido en cinco pedazos
iguales cada uno de esos pedazos tendría
que tener dos de esos cuadraditos y si
yo quiero dos quintas partes de esta
barra que tiene diez cuadrados pues dos
quintas partes serían algo a tomarme
todo esto de aquí y tomarme a su vez
todo esto de aquí estas serían dos
quintas partes de toda esta barra que
tiene cinco partes es decir
esencialmente lo que estoy haciendo es
tomarme a este cinco y lo estoy
multiplicando por dos para obtener este
10 de acá abajo lo estoy multiplicando
por 2 y si no estoy multiplicando por
dos a la parte de abajo de esta fracción
para obtener esta parte de arriba lo que
tengo que hacer también es multiplicar
este 2 x
lo que voy a hacer es duplicar este 2
para obtener la parte de arriba es decir
que es equivalente decir dos quintos que
cuatro decimos dos por dos es 44 sobre
10 es lo mismo que 2 sobre 5 y también
lo podemos ver visualmente si de aquí
tengo 10 cuadraditos y me tomo cuatro de
ellos voy a tener este cuadrado de aquí
este cuadrado de aquí este de aquí y
estoy aquí y te vas a dar cuenta que
llegamos justo a lo mismo ahora por otra
parte tenemos un medio un medio del
litro de pintura amarilla así que vamos
a ver lo mismo de una manera visual como
podemos encontrar un medio escrito
también en términos de decimos y para
eso también voy a traer una barra ok
perfecto con 10 cuadrados
con diez de estos cuadraditos y me voy a
tomar a esta barra dividida en dos
porque lo que voy a hacer es tomarme la
mitad de esta mar así que 1 2 3 4 5 aquí
está la mitad de esta barra y yo voy a
ponerle algo así y algo así ahora date
cuenta que si yo lo que quiero hacer es
sumar un medio de esta barra lo que
mueve a tomar es solamente la mitad de
la barra así que voy a tomar toda esta
parte de esta barra si lo queremos ver
de una manera matemática lo que voy a
hacer es tomarme este 2 y lo voy a
convertir en 10 y para esto lo que estoy
haciendo es multiplicando por cinco y
por lo tanto a esta parte de arriba
tengo que hacer lo mismo con ella tengo
que multiplicarla por cinco para obtener
el numerador de esta fracción y bueno
cuánto es 1 por 5 1 por 5 5 es decir que
cinco décimos es lo mismo que un medio
lo podemos corroborar aquí si nosotros
tomamos 1
2 3 4 5 de estos cuadrados te vas a dar
cuenta que llegamos justo a la mitad de
la barra y justo a donde llegamos ahora
si está padrísimo porque ya tenemos un
denominador común nuestro denominador
común es 10 y cuando tenemos fracciones
con denominador común ya no sabemos
sumar entonces cuánto es esto bueno pues
cuatro décimos más cinco décimos nuestro
denominador común es 10 y nosotros lo
que nos tomamos es la suma de los dos
numeradores es decir que lo que nosotros
tenemos que hacer es encontrar la suma
de 4 más 5 y todo esto sobre 10 y
también lo podemos ver de una manera
visual así que si a esta suma de
cuadraditos yo la junto lo voy a
encontrar con ok tomemos otro igual y
vamos a ponerlo por aquí primero tengo 4
cuadraditos rojos así que déjame
pintarlos de una vez tengo por aquí 1 2
3 4 cuadraditos rojos que es exactamente
lo mismo que dos quintos y por otra
parte le voy a sumar un medio que son 5
cuadraditos amarillos
así que 1 2 3 4 y 5 de ellos y entonces
me vas a poder decir que cuatro más 5
entre 10 esto es lo mismo que 9 décimos
es decir que todo lo que tenemos
coloreado aquí son 9 décimos del litro
de pintura pero qué crees esto no es lo
mismo que un litro completo de pintura
nos faltaría
para llegar al litro de pintura
anaranjada por lo tanto podremos
concluir que nos hace falta más pintura
o más bien que le hace falta más pintura
a camila y ernesto para terminar la
primera gigante que está naciendo para
las festividades de la escuela les falta
un décimo solamente para terminar esta
piñata y también tú lo podrías ver de la
siguiente manera dos quintos es más
pequeño que un medio y entonces algo más
pequeño que un medio más un medio no va
a ser lo mismo que un entero y tú te
puedes dar cuenta que dos quintos es más
pequeño que un medio de esta manera aquí
tenemos cuatro cuadraditos de color rojo
pero no tenemos cinco que es la mitad y
por lo tanto tanto de una manera lógica
como de una manera visual o matemática
podemos concluir que no se hace falta
pintura para terminar este proyecto esta
piñata gigante que están haciendo para
las festividades de la escuela así que
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo